باذنه يعلم
خفهم ولا يعطون بشيء من علم
وزرسي والسماوات والارض
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
قياط الصالحين الحفظ النووي
صلى الله عليه وسلم
النووي وعن ابي عبد الله خباب بن الارت
رضي الله عنه
خباب بن الارتك
مسلم
خباب ابن الارتف
‏unch
of the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
خبن
wasableنح
رضي الله عنه
بلال بن رباح رضي
‏would
desert sun andoneed on ch hours and
hours and hours in the baking heat
repeating enhanting احد
is less to the common masses
however
is noess compelling
خباب باب ابن الارت
رحمه الله ابن حجرشك
الاصابه
في تمييز الصحابه
خباب رضي الله عنه
مستلق على بطنه
‏and
would take out of the fire
and would all overهاد
[Silence]
نطable
خبابن الارت
‏was never cured from for
life and lived a fairly life and passed
away after the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
خبابن
had a lot of difficulty in life
now what do we
رضي الله عنه
عبد الله عبد الله بن خباب ابن الارت
ابو عبد الله عبد
خوارج
علين ابي طالب رضي الله عنه
toch
it
then took him butchered him you
would a goat on the
رضي الله عنه
[Silence]
خباب الارد رضي الله عنه هيز شكونا الى
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم وهو متوسد
برده له في ظل الكعبه
we the very small compl
was only صلى الله عليه
‏few
wom and fewaves this is all
and they being to torture and exile and
ridicule and communication
the prop
would go down afternoon time anday
[Silence]
‏and are around that is all different
leaders set up their
their and they would have their gathers
where they would deal with political
issues they would deal
‏and
go and would
inde and wouldite
would timeay would time
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
قريش
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ك فقلنا الا تستنصر لنا الا تدع لنا
الله
خب رضي الله عنه
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
خب
‏and to
why
if we were to
a difficulty comes and we make and go
away and time we have a difficulty we
make and makes it go away who loses when
that happens we
why is it that weuse
we never rise to the occasion
‏a
statem
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قد افلح من زكاها
‏where
دعاءه بالخير وكان الانسان عجولا الله
سبحانه وتعالى
‏which is
out of
beingy
tells the propes
to communicate
as the
ان شاء الله نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه
وكرمه وجوده ان يغفر لنا خطايانا وان يتوب
علينا اساله تعالى ان يلهمنا صبرا وان
يبتلينا
بما لا نطيق اساله تعالى الا يحملنا ما لا
طاقه لنا به وان يعفو عنا وان يغفر لنا
وان يرحمنا
وان ينصرنا على القوم الكافرين وصل اللهم
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين